christopher hitchens contributing editor
to Vanity Fair good morning thanks very
much for joining us Georgie and I are
syndicated columnist just back from
Kosovo why were you there and what did
you see well you know Steve I think one
of the sins of us in the press is that
we forget stories you remember two years
ago three years ago
Kosovo Sarajevo Serbia the Balkans were
big stories we invested we had a war
there in the spring of 99 and now no one
covers them you know we get one strike
we tend to do one story to the exclusion
of everything else in the world so I got
gee let's go to Kosovo let's go to
Sarajevo and see what's happened after
all these were the first un big un
missions and mandates and the fact that
they didn't work for so long I think I
know has lessons for us in Iraq and
that's why I went and that was my first
question to you because you you quote
President Clinton who is there saying
I'm quite aware of where you want to go
I believe in self-determination I want
to see you free the only question is how
you do it
what does Kosovo and Iraq have in common
that's the question it's it's how do you
do it in either place I'm not always
been an admirer of President Clinton but
I have to tell you Steve he was that day
he spoke in Kosovo at the University and
he was superb I mean people were crying
they were because they do feel that he
that he saved them from the server
aggression and in many ways he did now
what do you have to do he's saying they
should have independence which is what
many people feel but they're all tied up
because they belong to Serbia the UN
doesn't want to act the United States
doesn't want to act now because of Iraq
so in both places you have questions
nation-building you have questions of
untying these historic knots they're all
just tied up like this and now tied up
with the UN and with their own
governments and with Serbia and many of
those same questions are in Iraq
Christopher Hitchens in a vivid
description about your visit to Iraq you
say don't bother visiting Baghdad today
if you are too easily upset by
contradictions irony and negation are
the everyday currencies Iraq is a place
and Iraq as a country is a special
territory of archaeologists and then you
go on to talk about Saddam's morbid
mania for bearing things and people can
you elaborate
if I think it's on the next page is a
picture of about three dozen war plans
Iraqi war planes that were found buried
in the desert near an airport outside
Baghdad they bury everything they buried
they're very huge amounts of money for
example usually the constitute a rocky
people who are stolen from the National
Treasury to the tune of billions of
dollars American dollars in casual gold
some of this has been retrieved some of
it's being used to finance this campaign
of of murder and intimidation but to
bury a war plane is sort of crazy I mean
it's never gonna fly again if it's in
Bergen sir what are they doing that's
where I think by the way some of the
traces of their weapons program would
eventually be found have this mania from
internment but the worst of that is the
burial of people so you think they have
weapons oh I don't have any man I think
they had them we know they had them
because they declared them they just
never declared what they've done with
them I imagine that some of these
weapons of very under the sand the
ghastly thing they're a terrible thing
is we're still digging them up with our
the mass graves I went to the site in
Gila and southern Iran well they they're
still finding more and more mounds of
people it's estimation that there might
be as many as some 300,000 missing
Iraqis we found in that way they are
unearthed a mass grave almost every
every single day and that's true that's
the other measure of what kind of a
regime we were facing then and the
remnants of which were still facing now
do you mind if I make a small correction
well Giorgio interestings like I agree
with her the one shouldn't forget Kosovo
and Bosnia indeed it was there in my
opinion that American foreign policy
changed and where we had to take into
account the concept of humanitarian
intervention and actually what it is
this week is the anniversary of the
massacre at revenues Oh which the worst
the worst bloodletting in Europe since
the Second World War this about 7,000
men they took all the men out of the
village and just executed them
at least seven thousands worth damned I
just wanted to make a small correction
which is this you said that the problem
constitutionally with Kosovo's it's part
of Serbia well the Serbians may want to
claim that but it's never been
internationally recognized as part of
Serbia Kosovo recognized as part of
Yugoslavia and governed within old
Yugoslavia as a Serbian area but that's
it was not internationally recognized
except as part of the Federation of
Yugoslavia and now that the Federation
ceases to exist Serbia has no claim on
it at all and ran it as a colony are
much resented and hated and whatever
happens they're not they're not going to
go back to serve in rule well but that
is the official the officials set up is
that they are still part of Serbia
because well that's why they is still
just a remnant of Yugoslavia
yeah the relationship between between
Serbia and Montenegro they only are the
only other member of the former
Federation hasn't defected but I'll
repeat if international treaties never
recognized the Kosovo as part of Serbia
proper important I think because the it
was the mad scheme for a greater Serbia
company by ethnic cleansing that
necessitated intervention in the first
place and I also agree with you I'm not
a fan of President Clinton but I think
he and Tony Blair did extremely well
there finally in my only finally anyways
and this again is the foundation of an
alliance that I think has done such a
fantastic job in Iraq our phone lines
open we'll get your calls momentarily as
you well know General Wesley Clark has
talked about what he calls his success
in Kosovo as one of the reasons why he
should be elected president what's your
sense of Wesley Clark
his military background his success that
was a success in Kosovo and his
candidacy today well I know him quite
well actually I know when he was head of
the Southern Command in Panama and I'm a
great admirer of general Clark's I think
he even in his wife too is a wonderful
woman he he hasn't he really carried
that through greatly respected within
NATO I was talking to some of the NATO
people in Sarajevo the other day and
they said Oh every day when he would get
up on the screen and during that war and
he really pushed it because Washington
didn't want to go along with it on the
other hand there is
there's a kind of ambivalence about West
Clark like he's said the other day and I
I think you know I think he's fabulous
and I think he'd be a great president or
vice president but he did say the other
day on the record that he would have
voted for the Iraq war and then the next
day he said oh no he wouldn't have it
was by a resident a voted for a
resolution to take it to the UN and I'm
afraid you're gonna see some of that
with with West Clark but that doesn't
negate all the all the other terrific
things he's he's a real new balance of
factors within the Democratic Party
Christopher Hitchens let me read you
what Wesley Clark said in New Hampshire
yesterday and get your response in a
democracy were founded on dialogue were
founded on discussion were founded on
disagreement and even dissension and
it's not wrong it's the highest form of
patriotism to speak out and let your
voices be heard across the land the
headline says dissension is a high form
of patriotism Wesley Clark he doesn't
give one motion disagree with the does
he did want to respond to Georgia and
Gaia
well yes what it means since you know so
much about this and I'm just becoming
Clark conscious myself so I'm trying to
make up my mind how come he gets
photographed with a normal adage
exchanging hats and embraces I wanted
war criminal and psychopathic murderer I
criticized that at the time when when I
saw cuz I was covering the Balkans a lot
all over them during the 90s and I
really haven't seen what he did later
Christopher I can't I can't be too
critical it was there was such a
difficult time and all of the European
militaries worse slobbering up to the
Serbs I mean it was really appalling I
know but you see it's he shouldn't have
done it you know but he see what what
progress missed is he was apparently
told repeatedly before by superior
officers don't do that don't be fooling
around with more knowledge you know what
we think if it was a so there'll be a
matter of insubordination when it's it's
not it wasn't an unlucky accident wasn't
malaria saying grabbing a shot I mean
Clark permitted it to happen and the
same thing about a rug it's used to be
absolutely unbelievable that someone
would not by now know what their view of
Europe
general don't know anything about it rub
all perhaps haven't made up their mind
something wrong with everybody no is it
for you general
Evelyn Kennedy from presidency I think
you should probably know what your
position is right well had be that's why
I brought that up and then the next day
he he said now he didn't mean that and
it she goes then then find out he didn't
know even demand what it was this
bizarre GG IRAs syndicated column
appeared this weekend called Kosovo's
challenges and also Christopher Hitchens
who is that with the Vanity Fair article
called liberating experience his visit
to Iraq let's get to your phone calls
Chicago good morning Hilaire Belloc was
written in 1936 in it he says that the
most one of the most famous dates in
Western history should be September 11th
1683 when the Muslims returned back at
the gates of Vienna and then there was
another battle on Belgrade in 1697 I
always stopped fighting the wrong people
Belgrade the Muslims are the enemy and
if there was no September 11 2001 both
your guests would probably be fighting
for Muslim rights and Macedonia
mr. Hitchens well now I read a column a
couple of years ago saying I could at
least speculate I questioned in a
balcony that September the 11th was paid
for that reason because the the defeat
of the Muslim Turkish Empire of the
gates of Vienna in 1683 was the high
point of Muslim expansionism it's been
declining ever since and the bin Laden
is dream is to restore the old Ottoman
Caliphate and on the whole I think they
tried to go for significant dates I
don't know I've never had any further
confirmation also there's some people
who say that in fact the property will
be September the truth I suppose it
would depend on Vienna time and New York
time as well up to a certain point but
anyhow though it is greatly to the
credit I think the United States that it
rescued Europe's to range of Muslim
minorities in in Bosnia and Kosovo from
mascot
physical destruction it's it's very
noticeable that the Slobodan Milosevic
and his apparently secular National
Socialist regime fascist regime was
actually in close cahoots with that of
Saddam Hussein they traded weapons and
intelligence and they mutually exchanged
trainers and so forth there's there's a
lot of non sectarianism oddly enough
among Detailers in this kind Saddam
Hussein was perfectly happy to support
my loss which while he was murdering
Muslims those that I was saying like to
pose as a Muslim reader himself so I
think that you sir would be aiding and
abetting that kind of simplemindedness
if you if you persisted with the line of
thinking that we should have taken a pro
serbian position in the breakup of
Yugoslavia as some Democrats have argued
was the war fraud in Iraq they weren't
fraud in Iraq well we've given to us
Steve I mean every single point but I
wrote this before I wrote it at the time
I looked at the group's the
neoconservatives who were around
secretary Rumsfeld and Ron Vice
President Cheney all of these people who
have been pushing for a war in Iraq it's
in their writings it's in their paper
trail since the 1980s at least and not a
war in Iraq because of weapons of mass
destruction or September 11th because
that hadn't happened yet but to
reconfigure the Middle East and so yeah
I watched this all on I said there was
no connection between al-qaeda and
Saddam they hated each other actually a
Saddam was a heretic - he was a secular
bathurst I mean historically we know
that obviously no this weapons of mass
destruction I disagree with I with
Christopher on that I don't think there
I thought there were but I don't think
there right now to overthrow a tyrant
well we're gonna go into Burma we're
gonna go into Turkmenistan know every
single reason they gave for this war and
we have young American men and women
dying there and we have our nation on a
very different positioning in the world
I know where people used to love as an
example as an example they know aid us
as a self-described Empire so
yeah fraudulent I think is a kind word
what would be harsher what adjectives
would you know I think it was deliberate
misconceiving of the American people I
think it's very deliberate I don't think
it was accidental or they didn't know
this through that when the when the
president went to the United Nations
first to discuss Iraq he mentioned human
rights and genocide and he mentioned
terrorism as world's weapons of mass
destruction is basically told by the UN
will it will only discuss on one part of
this array will only will only do
weapons so that in a way conditioned the
way which I say at the end of my article
that she kindly referred to him and in
my book which I I hope you'll have tried
to wave at some points it's a long short
war but let's um
there is there is a distortion certainly
the way the war so but it came down
entirely to a matter of the weaponry but
a legalism a way of trying to legalize
it internationally but I'm perfectly
happy to say that I would be like the
neoconservatives I was looking for a way
of getting rid of Saddam I didn't was
anything dishonest in that at all and
and in the arguments that were put
forward for his removal there are four
ways in which you could say the
sovereignty of Iraq had been already
compromised one tendency strong one to
invade its neighbors to fooling around
with a non-proliferation treaty without
doubt never was in compliance with any
adverse event resolutions okay refused
to come into compliance with very
important resolutions on a very
important question and never gave any
account of what it had done with the
weapons it had disclosed its possession
of I think you're quite wrong in saying
there's no connection between Iraq and
al-qaeda al-qaeda members are being
thrown in Iraq as we speak this
relationship did not begin yesterday
which in Yemen Saddam Hussein and it's
not true at all true that's what I was
saying was a secularist for at least the
last ten years he posed as a Muslim
leader he put verses of the Quran on the
Iraqi flag he built mosques in his own
name and he was in bed with the Hamas
and Islamic Jihad forces in Palestine
betraying the PLO and going for the
Islamic
sadly the many more connections between
him and that are going to come and then
finally violated the Genocide Convention
and by the way their suicide the
Genocide Convention are obliged to act
on the on the discovery of genocide
without further ado without the journey
for another resolution you were supposed
to add at once both prevention to punish
you know there were those four things
there's a there's was an embarrassment
of reasons to get rid of Saddam Hussein
that they picked this legalized rather
pedantic matter of weapons of mass
destruction is is not is not terrible
and is not deceptive because the route
didn't just have these weapons in his
possession but had employed them against
their own civilians and against
neighboring countries so it seems to me
quite right to have said we will make
the worst assumption about Saddam
Hussein we will assume the worst of him
we will operate on the presumption of
guilt I think any other assumption would
have been highly irresponsible I
wouldn't have wanted Indian office
either in Washington or in London a
government that like the predecessors
had said well let's give Saddam Hussein
another chance absolutely wrong to have
done that for so long that the
extraordinary thing really is if you
look back at the whole record is not
with what a precipitate means in
arguments the British and Americans
finally got rid of Saddam Hussein is how
long they endured him how long they put
up with him how long they found excuses
for him how long they postponed what was
an inevitable reckoning question of it
if it fails Christopher Hitchens
concludes infinity here by saying so
dare to repeat in spite of everything
the breathless question what if it works
what if it works let's get your phone
calls Long Island New York we'll come
back to you George en Geyer
good morning good morning I'm calling
because number one I won I agree that
mr. Saddam Hussein was an evil man and
everything that mr. Hitchens just said
is correct
why did Donald run spell sake answer him
in Baghdad in the 80s when this star he
was using the mustard gas against the
Iranian that that wasn't even my point
calling my point for calling is
it is it true because you've been in
Baghdad in Iraq that the fundamentalists
are now a threat to the secular nature
of the country a woman from Montana
called in the beginning of the program
saying that we have liberated the Iraqi
women well is it not true that the Iraqi
women were the most liberated in all of
the Arab countries they went to school
they became professors they were they
did not wear veils but now they're being
kidnapped they stay home this is what
I've been reading in the papers and
listened on the website okay
thanks Colin the first point about the
picture with Rumsfeld and Saddam Hussein
yeah what that was
I think understandable because that was
during the 80s the threat then was
perceived and it was from the Ayatollah
Khomeini who was spread the first people
forget that was the big first attempt to
spread Islamic fundamentalism all over
the Arab world in the Muslim world any
he's certainly intended to and he tried
to the world for what started with with
Iraq and Roosevelt was there's the
American representative we had lots of
communications lots of connections we've
supplied them with all kinds of
intelligence that helped them fight the
Iranians and so on well yeah you could
say cynically times change but as a
matter of fact they do change and an
interest change changes as to the the
question of the women that's a very good
question I've been in Iraq seven times
since between 1973 and 1990 and I've
talked to the women and the movements
I've been all over the country and yes
they were very they they were
secularized he would seldom in Baghdad
seldom maybe is I would say of 10th in
those years people of the women would be
wearing veils they did not they were
westernized there was a very vibrant
women's movement and when a country goes
into the chaos that they have today and
the bath party which was a despite what
Christian Christopher says the bath
party was originally a secular didn't do
another impression that's the whole
point and and women were very important
part of it today in chaos their rapes
their murders the women King are afraid
to go out it's not surprising and you do
have people are worried about
a shiaa not conspiracy so much but that
there were an Iranian type Chism
fundamentalist government I don't think
that's going to happen that she is in in
Iraq are very very different people and
they fought on the Iraqi side in the war
with Iran I mean it's a very complex
country and those would be my answers to
those George and I are syndicated by the
LA Times and is in humming these papers
around the country 520 next call is
Edina Minnesota good morning good
morning it's Edina food I'm sorry good
one that's alright I had a couple
questions for Christopher Hitchens my my
questions have to do with the principles
of reconstruction in Iraq individual
freedom economic freedom and lastly
political freedom those institutions
firstly about the status of an IROC
Constitution the rule of law economic
freedom and then lastly öitís so most
people seem to be saying that democracy
will be the last piece or free and open
elections the second area has to do with
there's not hasn't really been a very
good comparison done between Europe
Germany after World War Two for example
in France there was a browned 35
thousand French reprisal murders of the
Vichy French that was said to going to
be happen in Iraq that we would have a
lot of reprisals also to the
institutions of the rule of law economic
freedom these type of things took place
over six to 14 months we have them some
of those things happening in Iraq and in
four months three to four months for
example I know they're coming out with a
new currency within the next month or
two and and that created economic growth
in world war one will work to in Germany
and in Russia call you have a lot there
let me give mr. Hitchens a chance to
respond thank you and if I was sort of
sensing about the previous questioner as
well because I think some of what she
addressed was to me to remember that any
any woman under the regime of Saddam
Hussein at any minute could be arrested
for no reason and how
- group of rapists and torturous and
that happened to thousands and thousands
and thousands of Iraqi women that's not
happening anymore important point as to
the rows field handshake and the rest of
it it it's true of course that there was
a time when the United States preferred
Iraqi defense to Iranian victory but I'm
afraid to say that this lists of policy
of indulging Saddam Hussein
followed the end of the iran-iraq war
and the United States was still
supplying him with a lot of very
important material at the time when he
was conducting his campaign of genocide
in Kurdistan and didn't have the
exclusive fending off their each other
so we have to face the fact that one
reason Envy why I'm so much in favor of
this policy is that it's so much better
than seeing American officials groveling
to Saddam Hussein which is what used to
happen it by October there will be a new
currency in Iraq and that'll be a huge
relief to everybody because the face of
Saddam Hussein will no longer be on the
money I think it's psychologically
important as well as commercially
important leap critical thing is going
to be getting the oil back on stream
people say it was a war for oil there's
one sense in which that's obviously true
until recently we'd nobody knew how much
oil Iraq was pumping or selling or what
price of where the money was going we
have a rough idea in each case it was
being run by a crime family in other
words but it Rupp probably has more oil
than Saudi Arabia in its reserves and
maybe that or listeners of higher
quality - it's potentially a
fantastically wealthy country and there
are various schemes here one of them is
to give what I believe in Alaska give
everyone a kind of share of every
citizen gets a dividend from the oil
industry that would obviously be a
wonderful thing for the Iraqis and it
would indicate that there really had
been a change of regime
others say that that that might have to
wait because we really are going to need
their money for reconstruction it would
of course be nice to make people feel a
bit wealthier but they're also
unbelievable infrastructure problems
from a regime that had bankrupted and
beggared the place and a lot of things
to be rebuilt but most of all you see
what's so great is to be able to be
having this discussion and to be able to
turn on the TV in Berlin
to see recognizable Iraqis who represent
real social and political forces and are
not members of of a sadistic mafia
discussing these important questions
that was it yatin tony pipes you spun
into a rocket is this from a viewer in
ohio should the iraqis have a right to
vote on whether they want to give their
wealth to corporations George and I well
I was in Sarajevo when it was announced
last week and my very my cynical first
thought was well we can't govern Iraq
we're going to sell it and I must say I
talked to some diplomats there who've
been in Iraq Western diplomats and they
were and they were there for various
Western governments and they were rather
startled by this too and and they didn't
approve but because what it would look
like to the Iraqis is that we are
selling the country and you know if you
can bring in all kinds of Western other
companies industries and make it into a
country that is owned by foreigners now
anyone who knows anything about Middle
Eastern history Steve knows that this is
not going to fly I mean the whole
history of the the Middle East in the
20th century was one of anti-colonialism
of getting the foreigners out of coming
out of the ottoman empire of all going
through all these experiments none of
them very successful but they were their
experiments and this is where I say hey
we're getting into something very very
dangerous peoples and particularly the
Iraqis above all will fight the occupier
and the and the colonialist long after
they've stopped fighting Saddam Hussein
our next caller watching us on the BBC
parliamentary channel which simulcast
this program on Sundays Cambridge
England go ahead hello thank you my
point I'd like to make first of all it
seems to be in America the humanitarian
reasons in wars it always seems to be
the Democrats who seem to be in power
when them cases are taken up and
whenever is a war involving two
Republican
it always seems to be for a different
ideological reason and with the second
point with the cases of live people
complaining about people the peace
movement and everything I think a lot of
the points people agree with the fact
that people like said I'm insane and
that should be removed but it's the
hypocrisy in America through the fact
that that America in itself has probably
got the most dictator like dictators
which have been in regimes living in
America in freedom in luxury come on let
me ask you specifically about what
happened yesterday about 20,000 people
in and around Trafalgar Square in London
about 3,000 in Paris and other protests
elsewhere in Europe
agree or disagree with that sentiment
they're not trying to put the right like
I don't think they're trying to put the
right message across
now what message should they put out the
chopping of arts gotta be done and
basically America fought for this and
one bit and they've gotta pay the
majority for it
Christians don't understand the question
at all it's only to say what's your take
on it I don't quite understand the
gentleman's question
could I just make a purchase okay still
with us caller you want to elaborate one
more time what a sign it's like that the
the multilateral system they're trying
us out an International Criminal Court
but everything America is doing is
undermining it by their agreements with
their own country no it's American
justice for American people but
multilateral justice for everyone else
bottom line do you agree or disagree
with our role in Iraq did we do the
right thing or the wrong thing okay
thank you
Christopher Hitchens this is an email
from Oxnard California has nothing to do
with the caller just asked about please
ask mr. Hitchens what he thinks of Al
Franken's a new book and is he glad he's
not mentioned in it again I'm really
sorry to be stuck with nothing to say
again but
I didn't know if I can call anyone you
know that no I wouldn't I mean I do
sometimes pick up books in stores which
I think I might be another quickly of
the index somewhere it's always between
Hitler and Hitchcock as well where was
where my name was well I already can be
featured tonight I go to the White House
wing of the Democratic National
Committee
yeah the conic wing yeah of the DNC well
this is the thing is either complete
hack I think he was even come in and
read Clinton is he's some he's think he
can be funny he used to be on Sunday
night like that kind of thing really
book against Limbaugh I remember in his
new book is had father never talking of
books that's a long short war it's the
postpone liberation of Iraq by
Christopher Hitchens this photograph I
guess knows when that is April the 9th
which is the new Iraq National Day this
was that a picture of you pulling the
sides no different I just left a rocket
you had that that is the far do square
paradise square in both at at the moment
when the dictator fell off the podium
that's the 9th of April which will be
the rock new governing council is
proposed should be the new National Day
speaking of photographs this is from
April 11th and a vehicle driving
underneath the victory arch modeled
after Saddam Hussein's own arm how large
is that did you were you there
personally
yeah that arm is let's see the two arms
together you can't see the birth of each
other just almost as tall as the Arc de
Triomphe in Paris if you can visualize
that and they were modeled from Saddam's
own forearms and underneath them is a
huge basket metal basket full of the
helmets of dead Iranian soldiers every
helmet has a bullet hole in it's like
seeing a part of skulls it's a an
absolutely barbaric monument that Sam
built to himself well as almost every
everything in Baghdad was named before
or after him and now it's going to be
the site of the museum of
the Iraqi and Kurdish Holocaust run by a
friend of mine named him the canal Makia
where himself very buried architecture
with book about this monument and who is
can you've written about him in the past
yeah he's wonderful guy and he's has the
institutional memory also the mass
murder in Kurdistan and in of the Marsh
Arabs and elsewhere so there's going to
be a library of museum commemorating the
the atrocities of the past regime in
Georgia entire you are now on your
eighth or ninth book ninth actually sing
and the new one is new book is on the
Royal and sacred cats of the world there
are all these cultures Egypt Burma Siam
Japan made cats into royal and sacred
creatures you probably don't know that I
did not know did you know that
Christopher cats them above and it's
calling we were talking before Yemen
where both of us are writing books and
things totally different than
geopolitics and we're we're so relieved
and the book is called raining cats the
Prophet Muhammad is said to have a cut
the sleeve of his robe rather than waken
a cat that had fallen asleep on his arm
and they're all innumerable cases in the
back of ruling factions or families
making cats as part of the part of the
earth very intelligent to I think do you
old Jasmine's to do that I have one cat
yeah one cat back tears
that's much better that's right better
than what well say them beautiful you
know because of Jesus Christ and so I
mean the nonsensical believes that
people have of that sort
far better to say that's perfect app do
you know what you're getting and this
rule will not be too exorbitant and you
won't be asked to obey impossible or
irrational Commandments Seattle good
morning are you at that lover to caller
yes okay my quickness for Christopher
Hitchens
Christopher what is your opinion of this
presidency since when it came to picking
a person to run their September 11th
commission they take Henry Kissinger and
in fact just someone you have offered
referred to as the pastor now there's no
doubt that Saddam Hussein was an evil
person but don't bother you that this
liberation of York came under this
president watch thank you I was very
opposed to having the Henry Kissinger
appointed to that Commission and I'm
more or less predicted in the protest
article I wrote about it that he
wouldn't make it however to confirmation
because in order to chair the commission
he'd have to open the books of Kissinger
associates his consulting firm and I
didn't think he would be willing to
undergo that kind of inspection of him
kissing associates is an outfit that
basically introduces despots to the
corporation's who like them it's one of
one of kissing has met many sordid
careers and I knew that if he had to
have disclosure he wouldn't he wouldn't
be able to submit to it so I was right
about that he gave up so also gave
people an opportunity during a number of
Republicans to see what kind of guy he
really is I mean having having said yes
I accept this great honor of finding out
what happened to our 3,000 missing and
murdered and fellow citizens he said
well naturally it's not such a great
honor if it compromises my business
posture gives you a rough idea of the
quality of the guy let's say mr. Paul
Bremer who I recently interviewed in
Baghdad he's in my piece was the number
of Kissinger associates - I have to say
that that that gives me a twinge also
but finally since you pressed me on the
question this administration actually
acted upon the resolutions that had
already been passed and the the stands
that Arabia taken about Iraq and I'm
glad that they did Christopher Hitchens
writes in the October edition of Vanity
Fair lest there be no confusion this is
George Clooney on the cover not
Christopher Hitchens
next is a call from Cumberland Maryland
good morning good morning my question is
for Georgie and I er I thoroughly
disagree with her article on Kosovo and
I'd like to educate her a bit I'd like
to point out that a kosovo ever gains
independence we will be having a greater
albania it will destabilize Macedonians
it will stabilize some of the Serbian
provinces the only way to deal with
cause of vote is let the Serbs have it
back and let the Serbs take control we
fought the wrong war over Kosovo because
all we did was support terrorism in the
form of the KLA and it will be the KLA
that will dominate that region and I'd
like her to comment on that
thank you I believe the lady must be a
serf because they are the only people no
saving not children no no but to put
forward that that position the Kosovo
was a region of Yugoslavia and it was I
was there in 1992 when it was under the
Serb police and it was I've been in a
lot of nasty places Vietnam Salvador
Iraq and during the iraq-iran war etc
etc and I had never seen such an
oppressive society as the one that the
Serbs ruled there the Kosovars had been
taken out of the universities the
schools were closed the health was
closed the health services were closed
the bank they couldn't the banks were
closed they were trying to make them
into a non-existent people as to so I
applauded our war there in 1999 I think
was one of the most virtuous and noble
things we we have done and rather
uncomplicated by that time after waiting
much much much too long as to a greater
Albania I mean there is nobody that
believes in a greater albania Kosovars
are far more advanced than the Albanians
if anything they would be a very good
example and a good reference point in
that in that area it's not decided yet
I think it could still go a lot of ways
but morally I mean to talk about this
in Kosovo as some kind of desirable
period of time or people is it's about
the same as talking about Saddam Hussein
as a as as a useful leader and actually
even if the lady was right about the
great for Albania threatened the KLA and
then there are some nasty people who
sure take an irredentist yeah yeah just
as a practical matter what I could say
from those visiting because for myself
not long ago there's no possibility of
it going bad too sad mineral I mean it
just is a physical impossibility you'd
have to kill everyone in good to make
the to make Serbian rule possible there
at the same time nobody the UN the
United States nobody is going to take
the really dramatic step that needed to
give it independence and so it's it's
it's tied up in all kinds and nuts right
now
Oceania California for Christopher
Hitchens and Georgie and guy you're next
good morning I was calling I was
wondering about the
c-span's institutional memory I was
remembering late 289 early 90 there was
a vote on the four billion dollar excuse
me I'm a little nervous I've never
called a more nervous - because I don't
know what you're gonna ask us for
billion dollar loan sort of noble
interest to Iraq and this is before the
war yeah yes in the Bush administration
first one and it was you know that
Liberal Democrats got up and they showed
the pictures of you know all these dead
Iraqis that have been the currents that
have been gassed the Republicans didn't
care at all it's business you know they
were you know the Iraqis killing the
Iranians Iranians killing Rockies
it's business we don't care as long as
we can get in there and make a deal
George and I yeah that happened I mean
we we gave them all kinds of stuff we
gave them intelligence during the
iran-iraq where we gave the Iraqis
intelligence that our satellites that
showed where the Iranians were we did
all kinds of stuff and our companies and
have and the Russians companies have and
the French in particular it's it's a
rich country and that worries me
it worries me now because when they said
last week
hundred percent of Iraq can be sold to
foreign companies outside of mineral and
extractive industries I I got a real
pain in my stomach
because you can see a lot of problems
coming coming with that I don't know
what to say to the gentleman but it's a
problem in the previous caller - were
talking about the the connection between
secretary Rumsfeld who was not in the
government at the time when he met with
Saddam Hussein the the the alliance of
convenience the Shah in the 1960s and
70s was that what Saddam was as he was
going after Iran it was definitely an
alliance of convenience at that time and
I'm not a purist I mean those things are
we paying a price for that today we pay
a place for all these things but you
know I'm supporting the Shah the Shah
was the moderniser the show it's the one
who it was going to bring his country
into the 21st century is that so we
don't it's not that you do everything
wrong it's that the world goes on in its
own way and people's go on in their own
way it's true about Jeb if the general
was still tuning in when we were talking
to the previous report of what I mean I
could I could not apply examples of
previous cynicism and complicity but I
think it deserves to be said that
cynical there's some of this has been it
it's not in the same class for cynicism
as let's say the policy of France
towards Iraq mr. shurok and the supposed
a tangi warriors mr. shurok for example
built under Saddam Hussein a nuclear
reactor knowing what he wanted it for
and French business interests were very
much involved in Iraq as well as were
Russian ones and French and Russian
businesses were owed a great deal of
money stolen from the Iraqi people by
Western arms and they had an interest in
keeping him going for that reason so if
this argument is going to tell this
argument about about cynicism and
collusion and exploitation it has to be
said to tell against those who were
against the war as well
Richard Holbrooke recorded in New York
Times piece this morning I don't have it
in front of me but he basically says the
relationship between the US and France
is not as bad
it may appear by some well I'm sorry to
hear that
that's I think presentation with mr.
shurok is absolutely essential French
ela naturalism a French colonialism are
a real threat to international order and
I think this high time there was a
confrontation where I find it will go to
Ocala Flordia good morning yes good
morning I'd like to make a basic
fundamental observation of my 53 years
of life I looked up in the dictionary
the word intellectual it states
reasoning versus emotional and I've read
both mr. Hitchens and the lady's columns
and I do see a great difference between
the two of the lady seems to be always
very emotional mr. Hitchens seems to be
reasoning quite a bit more and I think
it's a basic difference between the
conservative and the liberal party and
for the Liberal Party to stand on any
moral ground is beyond me when they
people they support or basically and
generally less moral and I would like
you a comment on my statement thank you
very much what do you consider me the
liberal of the conservative caller
because that wasn't changed me either do
you consider me the liberal answer
because for years I don't consider it a
conservative no I'm getting all these
emails saying but I'm you know I'm a
middle ground person now I'm getting all
these emails saying you tired or more
lefty and no a neocon I mean on the rock
oh yeah so fair enough and that is nice
when people notice if the from the New
York Times emotions of completely to be
distrusted serve on emotions prompt us
intellectually in the right way but
actually I did what dictionary gentle I
was using to look this up as far as I
know and I've always hoped that this is
true the term intellectual originates as
a term of abuse as of someone being
unsound and unreliable or possibly
treacherous I think it made it even it
originates as a word to sneer at the
supporters of captain Dreyfus
in France during the frame of the the
Patriots and the Catholics
and the militarists who wanted to keep
the frame up girl described those who
believed in the justice for a single
individual as mere intellectuals we no
concept of the national interest of the
higher I think that I think really will
you'll find that's true
and I hope the association with
subversion therefore stays in the
definition Alain Chileno writes the
column for this morning's New York Times
this is not as serious as people think
that's the quote from Richard Holbrooke
I referred to earlier he served as the
UN ambassador and also as at the US
ambassador to Germany none of us in the
loyal opposition understand why the Bush
administration hasn't co-opted Chirac
and said you want Arachne sovereignty so
do we our differences are only timing
and tactical again this is not as
serious as people think next call is
from Martin Tennessee good morning good
morning thanks for taking my call my
question goes to mr. Hitchens and it's
basically mr. Hitchens thanks strong
arguments for going to war with Iraq on
the basis that Iraq has indeed violated
so many UN resolutions and my question
is well what about the status of the
State of Israel
how many resolutions has the State of
Israel been in violation of over so many
years what about its possession of
nuclear arms and so on now what we here
to keep it would be his position on
something like that there are two
regional allies of the United States and
Middle East Turkey and Israel which
between them have a amassed a pile of
resolutions of condemnation from the UN
that would would be the equal of the
resolutions on Iraq you're quite you're
quite right Turkey for the occupation of
Northern Cyprus and the colonisation and
settlement as well as allegation of the
sovereignty of another state and Israel
for its attempt to incorporate the West
Bank into a into a greater Israel I I
think it's absolutely time that one of
several things at least happen either
the this I'm not trying to be funny the
United States Supreme Court should I
think rule that American aid may not be
spent on the west bank of the Jordan
River because it's an establishment of
religion and American money can't be
used for
settlements that have was their motive
of messianic redemption and the the
attempt to bring on Armageddon that's
what these settlers are trying to do I
think they should be stopped
I don't think a single dime of American
money should go for that and I think
that American forces would be
justifiably employed in removing them if
the Israeli government won't comply with
the resolutions from US News and World
Report's Senator Hillary Rodham Clinton
told US news that I was struck by
reading that after the first Gulf War
Dick Cheney said he would send a
thank-you note to Ronald Reagan you
always fight wars with the military you
inherited she said I don't think he's
done that to my husband I would be happy
to deliver it personally if he would
write it next call is from Spring Hill
Florida good morning I have questions
don't you agree sir that 87 billion
dollars is really cheap considering the
limited loss loss of life that we've
experienced and isn't that something
that the Republicans should absolutely
stand upon thank you vote if understood
correctly
I mean instant Benin is a large chunk of
change however however much of a bargain
it might turn out to be I think it could
be broken out a bit this figure is being
in history but made a bit more
transparent what the money is for and
how its to be earmarked and spent but I
personally think that I don't know if
you were watching earlier when dr. Baron
Sully was was on the show that the prime
minister of Kurdistan in Northern Rock
but he ought to be brought up now I
think the fact that the United Nations
oil-for-food program which turned out to
be an oil for palaces programmer and
generally very Mallard ministered a
scandalous abuse of the sanction system
nonetheless it did a producer breakages
money belonging which belongs to the
Iraqi people now being held in escrow
salat in French banks I think that
should be demanded by public opinion and
raised in Congress that this sum this
money to be released for the for the
reconstruction over August that's money
the Iraqis have already parted with and
should be being plowed back into their
country was supposed to have been spent
already
on the reconstruction of Kurdistan and
hasn't been there are billions of
unspent dollars in other words that are
being mal administered or sequestered by
the United Nations and it's time that
this we brought into play as well if
we're going to have to listen to
lectures from people that mr. Schirach
about the sovereignty of Iran Georgie
and gar this email how would the
situation in the Mideast today be
different if Ariel Sharon had not walked
through that Muslim holy place in
Jerusalem in the fall of the year 2000
there's just no question in my mind
Stephen to the the viewer that that walk
with 3,000 policemen and military
through the Temple Mount in September of
2001 started the was was the the act
that started the Intifada I was talking
in Europe the other day with you Elsie
Bailey and the marvelous former deputy
foreign minister and of Israel and one
of the most respected Israelis and he
said the Intifada was already planned
our GU T's one of the Palestinian
leaders who's more more respected had
come to him the spring before and said
we have to go to the streets because the
extremists are taking over from us he
said but the timing was sure owns Sharon
was the one that set it off and if you
look at Sharon's whole life this is what
he does you know I have a very
intelligent cat but my cat doesn't bark
he meows and sharone does what he does
he's a very violent man is a man of
chaos and he knows how to set off the
Palestinians who are who are very
chaotic and and just undisciplined in
their own way and very easy to
manipulate and so yes that that was you
know Yossi belying said to me just the
other day and I wrote it in my column he
said the timing was everything because
at that moment they had only a few
months to the election and they were
still negotiating in this destroyed all
possibility this godless thing about
what
Sheridan's he did all that to try and
undermine Bibi Netanyahu yeah in other
words this whole disaster is the result
of a factional squabble between two
right-wing Israelis for advantage this
is a nightmarish realization however I
mean actus agreed that it was a sorted
provocation so and from someone who also
be with you is a war criminal and who
was by the kahan Commission right it was
recommended to subarray Shatila we're
then finished with investigation that he
never be invited even to serve in any
Israeli government level every Prime
Minister pool should remember that but
it doesn't mean the Palestinians had to
act as if the provocation they were very
very ill-advised to take such a nice
defending their rationality that's not
the question but Israel is the dominant
power
Israel is the occupy well more to the
point if they didn't have a leader who
would say who they didn't have leaned
and felt you could say listen this is
not this is a leader who followed the
mob for a short time and plunged
everyone into this misery the balance
said that they met he was in the
government then the Baraat government
and he said they had to give her own
permission and he said we thought about
we worried about it we went over and
over and over it and we finally did it
because we said we can't we can't we but
not allow an Israeli leader to walk
through the Temple Mount with he said
three thousand I always had heard a
thousand but he was there and he said it
was totally wrong that we gave them
permission now we can see because it was
it was sure owns her own took over the
whole timing at that point our
conversation with Georgian Geyer who is
that with her latest book called raining
cats raining cats not quite yet but it
will be and Christopher Hitchens
Wednesday coming out next year oh I'm
sorry I thought was more recent and
Christopher Hitchens who has a new book
which we do have here called a long
short war the postponed liberation of
Iraq and also a piece in Vanity Fair our
next call Vegas ville California good
morning good morning first of all I
would like to say that George Ann Dyer
does give a fair and balanced history
and that is what I'm mainly calling
about I'm very
about how the rhetoric is guns those
deeds that they change the history of
what happened in Iraq and I happen to be
of the age where I remember exactly our
part in the Iran war and that the Iraqis
lost a million citizens also in the Gulf
War and by the way I had voted for
senior Bush in the Gulf War they have
the Kurds back them and what would we do
in our country if the if the Patriots
did work and our us okay I'll stop you
there thank you caller and I just like -
I appreciate the the caller's comments
very much because I think we're losing
track of one thing that's very important
here which were the principles and the
reasons for going to war all of which
have been shown to be untrue now I was
in Vietnam four times at the end of the
sixties in the early 70s it took us 20
years to come out of the fact of all the
lies that went into Vietnam and I see
that happening again and I don't believe
you couldn't go move on an unprincipled
manner in this country because this is
going to come out and out and out and
out for years just like it did for
Vietnam and are we gonna have 20 years
now to get out of out of Iraq the the
Gulf of Tonkin Resolution Michelle was
imagine what ya was tell the crux of
what yeah that was just one thing is
some was not just inventing a
provocation of pretending that being a
salver father the u.s. ship when there
hadn't been the point is if it would
have been misconceived if the hand if
there had been a vietnamese a challenge
it was the whole idea the United States
could arbitrate in the future of Vietnam
what could or should inherit the French
colonial rule there was wrong to begin
with so but the couldn't general words
have been a good or truthful even I
don't think that's the case in Iraq I
think the fact is that a long engagement
with Saddam Hussein's government had
demonstrated repeatedly that everything
short of regime change was a very
dangerous policy Christopher a quick
follow-up from an email that says
Gallagher did Kissinger really once say
that oil is far too important to leave
to the Arabs not as far as I know no I
can't say that I know that he said that
it does sound a bit like his rather
heavy a gross sense of humor I will say
Mansfield Connecticut good morning
go ahead Mansfield hi there I'd uh like
to talk Christopher Hitchens about a
couple of things first of all I'd like
to thank you for your support in Iraq
I've not read you you work on Kissinger
but I've read the latest book on Iraq I
wonder though how you reconcile some of
these views on Kissinger and some of the
things that how he's perceived in
Vietnam where I spent quite a bit of
time in the 1990s Kissinger Nixon
McNamara and these people are kind of
like national heroes their most hated
thing is the government followed by the
Communist Party and the most ridiculed
figure in Vietnamese history is Ho Chi
Minh I also find people in the media
perhaps you're too famous to find the
truth and places like that and if you
can find someone you're really trust and
send them in for a few years or not
known in and they'll come back and tell
you the truth or if you want to call me
back up here and we can talk about it
Christopher Hitchens your response well
I haven't been into China to confess I
would still be surprised to find that
Henry Kissinger was a street hero in
Vietnam or Cambodia or lasts after what
he did there
I can't obviously tell you that you
didn't hear or see what you say you did
but I also feel the program if it was if
it was true someone else would have told
me by now it's the first time I've ever
heard that final point for each of you
this is from Tom Friedman this morning
the New York Times the collective
response from mr. Bush's visit to the UN
this past week quote are you talking to
us this is your war pal we told you
before about Iraq you break it alone you
own it alone well you broke it now you
own it we've got you over a barrel
because you and your taxpayers have no
choice but to see this through so why
should we pay
this is the Thomas absolute right this
is exactly the outcome of people of
smart ass diplomacy and that's what
we've been waging smart ass diplomacy
yeah
insulting the whole world will go it
alone we don't need any of you now
suddenly we do know them the discourtesy
of this man the president who used to be
so courteous it's a very strange
transformation no I think the
president's much too polite to these
people myself and look look at what so
what kind of a responsibility what about
people saying okay we'll watch and see
how you go in Iraq we will we'll act as
if we doesn't matter to us at all as if
we have nurses and as if we had no share
in what happened to place this from
people who built Saddam Hussein a
nuclear reactor in the past they say
well you know we will watch you as if we
were neutral as if it didn't matter to
us and we reserve the right to precise
of course but we don't think we have it
outrageous
absolute outrageous neither I think that
the president should be a great deal
more forthright about that list than he
is mr. shurok would be in jail if he
wasn't president of France he had to run
in order to keep his immunity from
prosecution for fantastic corruption
mainly heal his party incidentally this
was crucial to before taking bribes and
foreign governments I would be very very
surprised if one of the first that
understand wasn't one of those it kicked
him so that these coffers I think this
would be well well within the rights of
the United States government to mention
this fact that we are dealing in the
case of the French regime with a rogue
state Christopher Hitchens pick up
Vanity Fair with his latest article also
his new book a long short war in Georgia
and Guyer
her new book on cats coming out next
year she is a syndicated columnist and
well over 100 newspapers around the
country thank you both for joining us
judgin come back again